HOPEFULLY WE CAN GET THE
EQUIPMENT WE NEED AT THE TIME WE
NEED IT.
THANK YOU FOR ALL YOU’RE DOING.
EACH NIGHT WERE GOING TO UPDATE
YOU WITH THE LATEST FACTS
WITHOUT FEAR INCLUDING
INFORMATION YOUR NOT GOING TO
GET FROM THE BIASED MEDIA MOB,
THEY ARE USING IT AS ANOTHER
OPPORTUNITY TO DO WHAT THEY DO
EVERY DAY AND THAT’S BAD
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
HOW MANY TIMES HAVE I SAID IT?
IF HE CURED CANCER, THEY’D
CRITICIZED HIM FOR THAT.
MISERY SEEMS TO LOVE COMPANY.
TRYING TO GET CALIFORNIA
GOVERNOR GAVIN NEWSOM TO SAY BAD
THINGS ABOUT THE PRESIDENT BEARD
UNFORTUNATELY, IT DID NOT GO AS
PLANNED, TAKE A LOOK.
>> DO YOU FEEL LIKE YOU HAVE TO
FEED THIS GUY’S EGO TO GET THE
RESPIRATORS AND TO GET PPE AND
THAT’S WHAT’S GOING ON?
>> ALL I CAN SAY IS FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE, THE RELATIONSHIP
HAS BEEN STRONG AND I’M NOT
DOING IT TO KISS THE RING AND
I’M NOT DOING IT IN A WAY -- I
AM JUST BEING FORTHRIGHT WITH
THE PRESIDENT.
HE RETURNS CALLS, HE REACHES
OUT, HE’S BEEN PROACTIVE.
WE’VE GOT THAT MERCY SHIP DOWN
HERE IN LOS ANGELES THAT WAS
DIRECTLY BECAUSE HE SENT IT DOWN
HERE.
>> Sean: BY THE WAY, THERE’S A
LESSON THERE FOR ANDREW CUOMO.
IN THE PRESIDENT IS GIVING YOU
THOSE HOSPITALS TO TAKE PHOTO
OPS IN FRONT OF.
HE’S BEEN BUILDING ALL THE
THINGS THAT YOU DIDN’T DO
YOURSELF.
GOVERNOR NEWSOM IS A FAR LEFT
DEMOCRAT AND HAS ABOUT 68
LAWSUITS PENDING AGAINST THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION.
NOT REALLY A FAN OF DONALD TRUMP
IT IS WORKING TOGETHER AND
LEADING HIS STATE AND MAKING IT
MORE SAFE AND SECURE, DONE A
MUCH BETTER JOB AND THEY’VE DONE
IN NEW YORK, I’LL TELL YOU THAT.
AND HE’S TELLING THE TRUTH AND
PUTTING PARTISAN POLITICS ASIDE
AND HE SHOULD BE COMMENDED
TONIGHT.
CUOMO ON THE OTHER HAND HAS BEEN
COMPLAINING EACH AND EVERY DAY
AND SURE, HE’S GOING TO SHOW UP
FOR A PHOTO OP, AT THE
JAVITS CENTER HOSPITAL THAT
DONALD TRUMP AND THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT CONSTRUCTED, THE ARMY
CORPS OF ENGINEERS ACCEPTING
THOUSANDS OF VENTILATORS,
MILLIONS OF MASKS AND GOWNS AND
GOING AROUND ON TV AND TAKE A
PHOTO UP IN FRONT OF THE SHIP,
THE COMFORT WHICH ONLY 20 PEOPLE
TODAY, I’M NOT SURE WHY, AND
BASH THE ADMINISTRATION
DEMANDING THEY DO THEIR JOB
YESTERDAY TWEETING "WE DO NOT
HAVE ENOUGH VENTILATORS PERIOD."
SO HOW MANY VENTILATORS IS HE
SHORT?
HE DOES REALIZE THEY WERE 50
OTHER STATES THAT ARE DEALING
WITH THE VIRUS.
TODAY DURING HIS DAILY BRIEFING,
THE PRESIDENT ADDRESS THIS VERY
ISSUE, LET’S TAKE A LOOK.
>> THEY SHOULD’VE HAD MORE
VENTILATORS.
THEY WERE TOTALLY UNDERSERVICED.
WE ARE TRYING TO DO OUR BEST FOR
NEW YORK.
WE HAVE STATES, WE HAVE A LOT OF
STATES, WE HAVE TERRITORIES TOO,
BUT WE HAVE A LOT OF STATES THAT
HAVE TO BE TAKEN CARE OF.
SO MUCH MORE SO THAN OTHERS.
WE WORK VERY WELL WITH THE
GOVERNOR, WE HAPPEN TO THINK
THAT HE IS WELL SERVED WITH
VENTILATORS.
WERE GOING TO FIND OUT THAT WE
HAVE OTHER STATES TO TAKE CARE
OF.
>> Sean: EVERY NEW YORKER
NEEDS TO KNOW WHAT AN EPIC
FAIL -- GOVERNOR CUOMO HAS
FAILED THE STATE OF NEW YORK ON
A TERRIBLE LEVEL.
AFTER ALL, NOVEMBER 2015, HE WAS
GIVEN -- WILL SHOW YOU THE
REPORT, AN IMPORTANT REPORT FROM
NEW YORK STATE’S HEALTH
DEPARTMENT.
LET ME READ FROM PAGE 30.
SAYS "DURING A SEVERE INFLUENZA
PANDEMIC, THERE IS LIKELY TO BE
A PROJECTED SHORTFALL OF
VENTILATORS.
15,783 DURING PEAK WEEK DEMAND."
AFTER READING THIS REPORT, CUOMO
PURCHASED ZERO VENTILATORS FOR
NEW YORK.
BY THE WAY, SMALLEST
GEOGRAPHICAL LOCATION WITH
11 MILLION PEOPLE,
NEW YORK CITY.
INSTEAD, HE INSTRUCTED THE
COMMISSION TO FIGURE OUT WAYS TO
RATION THE EXISTING 2,000
VENTILATORS.
THE NUMBER ONE TARGET OF
TERRORISM, THE NUMBER ONE AT
RISK PLACE IN THE COUNTRY FOR
DISEASE, THE MOST DENSE
POPULATION HAS A SHORTAGE OF
VENTILATORS.
HE WOULDN’T BUY THEM, BUT HE
WASTED 750 MILLION ON A SOLAR
PROJECT, ANOTHER 600 MILLION ON
ANOTHER IDIOTIC PROJECT,
$90 MILLION ON THE LIGHT BULB
PROJECT AND HE WOULDN’T BUY THE
VENTILATORS.
NOW BECAUSE OF AN EXECUTIVE
ORDER IN NEW YORK, ANY
PRESCRIPTION OF THE POTENTIALLY
LIFE-SAVING TREATMENT
HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE, IF YOU WANT
IT, YOU’VE GOT TO GO TO THE
HOSPITAL SYSTEM WHICH IS ALREADY
OVERRUN.
SO IN OTHER WORDS, YOU CAN’T
HAVE YOUR DOCTOR CALL INTO YOUR
PHARMACY IN CONSULTATION WITH
YOUR DOCTOR, HE WON’T LET THAT
HAPPEN AND CUOMO, WHY?
I THOUGHT YOU WERE PRO-CHOICE,
GOVERNOR.
LET NEW YORKERS IN CONSULTATION
WITH THEIR DOCTORS DECIDE.
THE PRESIDENT WHEN YOU ASK HIM
LIKE EVERY OTHER TIME BAILING
YOU OUT, I’M SURE HE WILL SEND
YOU THE HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE, JUST
ASK.
INSTEAD, HE GOES OUT ON TV,
POUNDS HIS CHEST, ALL TALK, NO
ACTION, BLAMES THE PRESIDENT AND
HIS OWN HEALTH DEPARTMENT TOLD
HIM TO BUY THEM.
HE REFUSED AND WASTED HUNDREDS
AND HUNDREDS AND EVEN BILLIONS
OF DOLLARS.
THE MOB IN THE MEDIA LOVE
GOVERNOR CUOMO GOVERNOR CUOMO.
THEY TREAT HIM LIKE HE IS A
HERO.
HE FAILED THE PEOPLE OF NEW YORK
AND HE TREATS THE PRESIDENT LIKE
GARBAGE IN THE MIDDLE OF A
NATIONAL CRISIS, THERE IS NO
HELP TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE,
NONE.
HOW DID YOU NOT PREPARE?
THE NUMBER ONE TARGET OF TERROR,
UNBELIEVABLE.
AND IT’S ALL OVER THE MEDIA AS
WE NOW GO THROUGH AND A LOT OF
THE MEDIA MOB IN DIFFERENT WAYS
AND YOU WATCH ON MORNING MEDIA
WHAT THEY SAY OVER THERE, FAKE
NEWS SAYING THAT ALL OVER.
BELIEVE IT OR NOT, DON LEMON
PRETENDS TO BE A NEWS ANCHOR
OVER THERE AND IF HE WERE AN
ACTUAL JOURNALIST AND THIS W
AN ACTUAL NEWS ORGANIZATION AND
HE WAS IN A PARTISAN HACK AND
THEY DIDN’T HAVE A LEFTIST
AGENDA WHEN THEY WERE OBSESSED
WITH THE IMPEACHMENT WITCH HUNT,
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WAS
WARNING AMERICANS ABOUT THE
CORONAVIRUS.
DECEMBER 27, CHINESE OFFICIALS,
WORLD HEALTH ORGANIZATION, THEY
SAW THAT WORK THERE WAS SOME
TYPE OF PNEUMONIA LOOKING LIKE
VIRUS AND THEY DIDN’T KNOW WHAT
IT WAS CALLED, PEOPLE WERE
GETTING SICK.
DECEMBER 30TH IS WHEN THEY FIRST
FOUND OUT.
THEN JANUARY 6, THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT STARTED ISSUING
WARNINGS.
FOLLOW THESE DATES, JANUARY 20,
CDC, EMERGENCY OPERATIONS
CENTER, JANUARY 31ST, 10 DAYS
AFTER THE FIRST KNOWN U.S. CASE,
PRESIDENT TRUMP ISSUED THAT
TRAVEL BAN AND CONDUCTED A
MANDATORY QUARANTINE IS
FOLLOWED.
LOOK AT YOUR SCREEN, EVERY STEP
OF THE WAY, THE ADMINISTRATION
TOOK UNPRECEDENTED AGGRESSIVE
ACTION AND GOT IT KICKED OUT OF
IT, RACIST, XENOPHOBIC,
HYSTERICAL, FEARMONGERING.
THINK ABOUT IT THIS WAY,
DR. ANTHONY FAUCI SERVED SIX
PRESIDENT THAT HAS BEEN A
CHAMPION OF FIGHTING PANDEMICS
AND I MEAN THAT.
HIGHLY RESPECTED IN ONE OF THE
MOST TRUSTED EXPERTS IN THE
FIELD.
DR. FAUCI DIDN’T REALIZE THE
TRUE THREAT OF THE VIRUS ON
JANUARY 21ST.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> BOTTOM LINE, WE DON’T HAVE TO
WORRY ABOUT THIS ONE, RIGHT?
>> OBVIOUSLY, YOU NEED TO TAKE
IT SERIOUSLY AND DO THE KINDS OF
THINGS THAT THE CDC AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND SECURITY
ARE DOING, BUT THIS IS NOT A
MAJOR THREAT TO THE PEOPLE OF
THE UNITED STATES AND THIS IS
NOT SOMETHING THAT THE CITIZENS
OF THE UNITED STATES RIGHT NOW
SHOULD BE WORRIED ABOUT.
>> Sean: VERY WELL RESPECTED,
NOT TO SAY ANYTHING BAD ABOUT
DR. FAUCI, HE WAS LIED TO BY THE
CHINESE GOVERNMENT.
JANUARY 26, TAKE A LOOK.
>> THE AMERICAN PEOPLE SHOULD
NOT BE WORRIED OR FRIGHTENED BY
THIS.
IT’S A VERY LOW RISK TO THE
UNITED STATES, BUT IT’S
SOMETHING THAT WE AS PUBLIC
HEALTH OFFICIALS NEED TO TAKE
VERY SERIOUSLY.
>> Sean: FIVE DAYS LATER,
PRESIDENT TRUMP ENACTED A TRAVEL
BAN.
HOW MUCH WORSE WITH THIS I’LL
BE?
AND I’LL GET THIS, JUST BREAKING
TONIGHT.
THE EVER SO CLUELESS AND OUT OF
TOUCH QUID PRO QUO JOE.
REMEMBER HIM?
HE IS RUNNING THOSE BAD
PODCASTS.
INITIALLY CALLED THE BAND
XENOPHOBIC, HYSTERICAL, AND
FEARMONGERING.
LOOK AT THIS NEWS.
JOE BIDEN NOW SUPPORTS THE
PRESIDENT’S TRAVEL BAN WITH
CHINA.
THAT’S TWO MONTHS AND THREE DAYS
TOO LATE.
AND NOW EVERY DEMOCRAT RUNNING
FOR OFFICE NEEDS TO BE ASKED THE
SAME QUESTION.
IS ASKING NOW IN RETROSPECT, WAS
DONALD TRUMP RIGHT?
THIS WAS BOLD AND UNPRECEDENTED,
UNTOLD THOUSANDS OF AMERICANS
DIDN’T CONTRACT THE VIRUS AND
MANY OTHERS DIDN’T DIE.
IN CHINA LIED TO THE WORLD.
THAT’S WHY DR. FAUCI DIDN’T
KNOW.
IT’S NOT HIS FAULT, BUT STILL
THE PRESIDENT GOT IT RIGHT FIVE
DAYS LATER.
THEY LIED ABOUT THE NUMBER OF
CASES, THE AMOUNT OF DEATHS, THE
WAY THE DISEASES SPREAD, THEY
BLOCK TO USE U.S. RESEARCHERS,
THEY SPREAD THEIR LIES AND
PROPAGANDA.
THEY WERE A DISGRACE AND WE
SHOULD HAVE NOTHING TO DO WITH
THEM DOWN THE LINE.
ONE STUDY IN THE U.S. FOUND
CHINA HAD BEEN HONEST SOONER,
THAT STUDY 95% OF ALL OF THIS
COULD HAVE BEEN PREVENTED.
THE MOB IN THE MEDIA DON’T CARE
ABOUT TRUTH.
THEY’RE JUST WORRIED ABOUT
SCORING CHEAP POLITICAL POINTS
AS DEMONSTRATED BY FAKE NEWS
ACCOSTED TODAY.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WHERE IS DR. FAUCI?
>> I DON’T KNOW, BUT EVERY TIME
YOU ASKED THAT QUESTION, YOU SAY
WHERE IS HE AND YOU SAY IS THERE
A PROBLEM?
NO PROBLEM WHATSOEVER.
EVERY TIME HE’S NOT HERE.
SOMETIMES I’LL ASK HIM TO COME
BECAUSE IT’S THE FIRST QUESTION
THAT YOU AND A COUPLE OF OTHERS